on peut le féliciter sur sa
communication parce que le prénom d'un
gué sur la culpabilisation des gens qui
bénéficient des aides sociales mais moi
je voudrais lui rappeler qu'il ya des ja
la cmu qui existe à fait il y avait le
rmi il ya le rsa aujourd'hui et tous ces
dispositifs la sueur des dispositifs qui
aide beaucoup à les évaluer les effets
prendre contact avec les présidents de
conseils départementaux et puis ils vous
rendront des comptes sur la manière d'en
laisser opération à chaud conduite et
les résultats qui est des résultats ça
ne permet pas d'endiguer la porte du
vestiaire et interrogé un moment donné
moi je suis complètement d'accord parce
que nous touchent et et évolue parce que
il faut que l'on regarde un petit peu
comment on peut être plus efficace plus
opérants kythera mais je reviens sur
cette idée que les aides sociales qui
existent aujourd'hui et la solidarité
qui est exercée aujourd'hui elle est
efficace dans 90% des cas
alors qu'il ya 10% de gens qui en tirent
profit de manière exagérée rochant doute
mais je crois moi d'efficacité je
rappelle la cmu c c'est pas rien ça
s'est vu car mes deux points mentionnés
des rappels on a pensé que la réponse à
la pauvreté c'est l argent or
aujourd'hui il fait ce constat est bien
que la pauvreté continue qu'il ya une
sorte de déterminisme social qui ronge
finalement la société française non le
leur réponds tu sais pas s'il me fait si
l'argent mais ces termes est provisoire
bon on sait très bien qu'aujourd'hui
sirigu des pensions beaucoup bon le chef
de l'état l'a rappelé sa faconde c'est
vous avez parlé de fraude aussi ces
ricains problème des fraudes moi je
pense qu'il faut il va falloir revoir
complètement le système de distribution
pour adapter réellement les aide aussi
adapté en fonction des situations on ne
peut pas faire du vrai dire les noms
comme le propose on peut pas faire du
cas par cas à l'échelon national mais
mais ce se pencher réellement sur les
aides sur les aidants qui vous
intervenez chez ses jambes pas par par
l'éducation après derrière pour les
remettre sur les rails pas c'est vrai
qu'il y en a qui naissent complètement à
côté du système qui reste beaucoup trop
alors quand même notre république qui
permet d'avoir des produits de la
république justement qu'ils déploient
beaucoup de moyens en terme d'éducation
en termes d'ajustement pour les remettre
dans le bon sens donc effectivement ça
on dépense beaucoup
autant d'argent on en gaspille ou si
c'est vrai mais faut revoir la copie on
va retourner à montpellier puisque rien
de mancini à nous attend avec jean
pierre grand et sénateurs l air de
l'hérault c'est à voir yann oui delphine
bonjour monsieur le sénateur vous êtes
au premier rang lors de ce discours du
président de la république
qu'avez vous pensé du discours d'
emmanuel macron d'abord c'était un très
beau discours je lui ai dit en
plaisantant qu'il avait fait un beau
discours gaulliste il me dit qu'il va
suer
il a bien cerné la situation de la
nation
alors bien sûr les mesures qu'ils
annoncent sont des mesures qui sont
celles d'une réflexion sur le
vieillissement sur les soins des
personnes qui n'avaient pas accès aux
soins qui ont toujours pas accès aux
soins
naturellement on y pense et là c'est
plus comme progrès social c'est un
progrès humain alors après naturellement
il va falloir voir pour les volets
moyens pour mettre tout ça tout ça en
place mais à la fois sur le lit souvent
sur l'aller les jeunes parce que j'ai
entendu qu'ils voulaient qu'on revienne
au dépistage y compris au dévissage dès
le plus jeune âge
donc tout ça est quelque chose
d'important on va voir maintenant
comment ça va s'articuler
on va voir quels sont les moyens qui
vont être mis à sa disposition ma barbe
mais globalement c'était un discours qui
prenait en compte les problèmes de la
société les problèmes de santé les
problèmes vieillissement et en ce qui me
concerne moi qui ai été maire pendant
plus de 35 ans je dois dire que j'ai
ressenti toutes les difficultés que nous
connaissons dans nos communes et que
nous essayons naturellement de surmonter
à l'importante des aides et des
structures les ehpad les ehpad
ça c'est quelque chose aussi de très
importants lui seulement voilà et puis
bien sûr les soins de faire des soins
auditifs les soins vise yeux de visuels
ça c'est quelque chose aussi de deux
majeurs parce que c'est une grande et
belle
égalité républicaine de pouvoir se
soigner justement sur cette annonce sur
le reste à charge 0 qui entrera en
vigueur prochainement est-ce que selon
vous les français doivent craindre une
augmentation des prix de leur mutuelle
alors il n'est pas allé il n'est pas
allé dans le financement il n'a pas
abordé sa il a qui n'est pas une réforme
on voit cette réforme va être très
certainement présenté au parlement
il ay là il a dit au la mutualité que
bhl actuellement ils seraient des
acteurs majeurs un bon il va y avoir
plein d'acteurs majeurs l'état pas
pouvoir faire ça tout seul bien sûr mais
je voulais il ya une ligne
voilà après mais voilà il faut la mettre
en oeuvre et est bon et puis à ya
quelques années pour mais ça avait de la
gueule
autre annonce a fait par emmanuel macron
c'est cette loi sur la dépendance qui
sera examinée au parlement avant la fin
de l'année est-ce que selon vous les
gouvernements précédents et les
gouvernements successifs ont trop tardé
à prendre en main ce problème de la
dépendance on veut pas dire ça comme ça
parce qu'aujourd'hui chaque année qui
passe nos coins le vieillissement de
concitoyens est un petit peu plus
vous n'êtes pas important il ya eu
beaucoup de choses de faites beaucoup de
choses il suffit de regarder ce qui
s'est fait larguer dans les villes
partout il ya beaucoup de chocs mais non
il ya une nouvelle étape qui s'ouvre et
je pense que ce projet de la de loi sera
le projet pour une nouvelle étape
le financement de la dépendance c'est
c'était un gros gros sujets en poussant
ses étudiants par le discours d'
emmanuel lacroix est ce qu'il ya quand
même des choses qui vous ont déplu dans
son discours tout va non parce que il
n'a pas dit de choses déplaisantes je
vous ai dit qu'il avait fait un discours
humain discours qui prenait en compte
les réalités de la société d'aujourd'hui
et puis naturellement les faiblesses les
faiblesses pour y répondre
voilà après après on va voir ce qu'ils
me ce qui est mis en avant pour régler
les problèmes et et surtout financer les
mesures
merci beaucoup